[Musique]
la majorité absolue des membres du
conseil départemental
il tente 26 voix monsieur cyrille
melchior a obtenu 38 voix par conséquent
et est élu président du conseil
départemental de la réunion
[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit comme l'huile et cyrille
melchior a été réélu président du
département de la réunion
unique candidat de ce scrutin il a
obtenu 38 voix sur les 50 conseillers
départementaux appelés aux urnes série
mais le coeur va donc effectuer un
nouveau mandat à la tête du palais de la
source
tous nos remerciements l'ensemble des
personnes qui ont voté en ma faveur je
serai un président comme l'a dit
monsieur andré thien ah koon de dialogue
qui travaillera avec l'ensemble des
personnes élues parce que le suffrage
universel s'est exprimé et comme vous
l'avez vu encore une fois ce matin nous
avons l'expression démocratique et donc
respectueux du suffrage universel
je vais servir la population
réunionnaise comme je l ai toujours fait
avec humilité mais avec beaucoup de
détermination amandinois rôle des
nouveaux visages de cette assemblée
rajeunie a eu l'honneur de présider
cette élection et 20 beaucoup
d'émissions cette journée parce que ça
n'arrive pas
quand même
soit il faut simplement entamé les
dynamiques
sean du discours du président réélu un
vote a eu lieu sur la composition de la
commission permanente composée de 36
membres dont 15 vice-présidents série
mêle qui aura fait l'unanimité car une
seule liste a été déposée
je pense pas que ce soit une histoire
deux premières places c'est de pouvoir
continuer le travail que nous avons
engagées au prix de ces auprès de
cyrille melchior le président depuis
et c'est dans cette continuité d'action
que nous allons poursuivre nos missions
nos missions en direction de l'ensemble
des acteurs du monde social les
personnes âgées les personnes porteuses
d'un handicap pour les enfants également
pensez également à au monde agricole
puisque je crois plus que jamais
l'agriculture sera positionné en bonne
place ici au conseil départemental nous
allons continuer le travail qui a été
également commencé et puis le glas
collèges les routes départementales tous
les sujets et je crois que il est le
moment est aussi venu pour nous d'avoir
un vrai plan départemental en direction
des personnes âgées personnes
handicapées notamment sur l'accueil de
ces personnes
nous avons connu des moments douloureux
au cours de la fin de notre mandature
avec notamment les pensions marron je
crois qu'aujourd'hui le département doit
absolument mettre les moyens pour
pouvoir pour trouver des solutions pour
ces personnes lors de la séance plénière
qui se déroulera le 28 juillet prochain
les conseillers départementaux
désigneront les différentes délégations
des élus ainsi que leur représentation
au sein des commissions des organismes
extérieurs
[Musique]